spins in the corner trying to find
a lane to the net look out front sta
was there was high in the air comes to
Sanderson at the point he finds Joseph
just couldn't let it go Matthew
Joseph turns with it now he fires
[Applause] scores K tipped it in
the Senators are on the board first
but not anymore he gets back into play and the
scene play from Sanderson to Joseph allows him
to walk around the top of the circle and
nobody adjusts and a lot of people will
tell you that the system has changed for
Tampa Bay this is a team that used to play
man on man in the zone now they're playing more
of a zone defense piz can't get there in time d
off centers Point couldn't shoot it right
away and now sck handles back to the line
sends it for COV in the corner centering
pass made it towards the goal they scor
headman he found the bouncing puck in the
slot and ties the game at one didn't take
John Cooper long to put coocher off and point
back together and it results in a goal I mean
he he sent his message to them and maybe he's
going to put them back together now and say
okay deal happen Point good Puck possession he
rolls out to the top sto Laz on it and then he
rotates it back to coer off and then this Puck
comes right across the headman it's a bit of a
unfortunate bounce for the Senators but at
the end of the day you got all your bodies
in place everyone is back in the area and you
see Hegel picked it up by Bernard Docker but
nobody R kchu turns in the lightning Zone
in the corner spins and blew a tire there
right back up and on the puck comes to the point
hammock and he pinballed that one and made it to
the net hon the save hammock's got to get the
back his point Bears down on him greaten Point
scores just 32 seconds into the period Braden
Point gets around the corner and goes roof it
gets your attention and just chatting with people
from Tampa Bay they were saying that expect this
guy to really come at it tonight he's already
got an assist on the first headman goal and
here he's going to pop on himself comes down the
wing great skating he never stops his feet from
moving he picks his spot wristed in from Center
Binet Let It Go here's hamic a shot blocked by
selli who's got him back the other way right away
here's asot trying to Barrel through Mikey asot
scores split the D and it looked like he was
handled but just got a stick on it to roll it
over the shoulder of coras solo it is 3-1 Tampa
the tape right here Celli blocks the shot gets it
to asmal yes he tries to get the puck over to the
wing but he doesn't get it over but he stays with
it right there he tries to throw it it goes off
the skate of Sanderson Ham's coming over and at
some point I think you got a lower the boom on him
if you're coming over and you're the body don't
stick check lost the handle went down to a knee
CRA back the other way point side the goal tied
across the blue ice and cor pasalo got the pat
across in time to stop B cleven across for Nick
M Paulo looks ahead and the long pass finds bers
with some room here's s to Chuck rebound BS and he
just missed it in the frame is COV off the faceof
wind tipped on the way through it's loose and they
score and there's a lot of confusion around the
Ottawa net as it was tipped in onto forsberg he
thought he had it the referees saw it loose and
didn't blow it dead I think this is braen Point
again fire has been L under braen point he wins
the draw to coocher off there's the initial shot
that bounces around and then I think point
just jams at it you know forsberg's looking
around so there's point you see him he goes over
the back leg of forsberg right there to look and
then he realiz is the puck is sitting out in
front he has a peak over the back it's out in
front and then he pokes it in Renard Docker
that one went off a stick and wide sta gets
it on the far boards switches with ch Tim stla
Jacob Bernard Docker stoa one timer [Applause]
scores clu the blast an early goal from
the Senators gives them life the C comes
over lowers the boom on radish just right
in front of us big hard contact he lets
his teammates know I'm not letting this go
yet we got life left in us then they get
into the Zone they move the puck around and
jeru loses himself in the quiet zone of the
ice he backs himself up towards the blue line
and there's no adjustment made by the Tampa
Bay Lightning nobody adjusts Dand lays it out
to jaru it's a great onetime and K Le gets it
back to tricken Across The Blue Line tereno
couldn't handle it but sends it deep Joseph
lets it go zaru on the far side he controls
across for Joseph and he bed it on goal still
loose B on the pass still ends up on the stick
of Nick Paul to gain the Zone stanos across for
Cova COV looks back for stanos Waits now fires
a score and it's Bren point the hatri goal for
point off his line he challenged braen point to
be the braen point that he could be and he has
stepped up big time tonight I mean he has been
a I mean right there absolutely give the girl
lot of credit to Stam Co who puts that right
in the right spot but Point has been a factor
beautiful set up from bson now Sanderson his shot
rebound there for kru clear to the boards Norris
able to keep it in K shuck [Applause] scores the
captain's going to look for the Tampa bench after
that one it's 53 I mentioned that after drawing
this you've got to strike if you're Ottawa and
they do a pretty good looking power play they had
Puck possession every time the puck was 50/50 they
got it but that block along the wall by Norris
was huge kachuck and he buried it first Power
Play goal surrendered on the road by the lightning
this season but here right back is bar ble Co off
scores and just like that Tampa responds keep
them under wraps and here Puck goes off Jeff
goes off CH and skate and then just ends up being
in a real tough spot down low it's a two-on one
and the T Bay Lightning get that three-goal lead
again in the back row here's a chance in front
all alone [Applause] [Music] scores Drake Bon's
been feeling the pressure only one goal on the
season he was the first one out for more skate
taking extra shots John Cooper his team just
keeps letting Ottawa hang around and you hate to
do that the senators in good on them poor play
coming off the boards radish misses his guy bson
goes to the net and good job along the boards by
number seven the captain kachuck and he wins a
battle after C Bas coaches challenge it was Z
the puck was not hand pass therefore this is
a good goal oh it took a while in his third
period boaro will gain his own chips
to across for teraso and rebound two
KCK was stopped by Johansson
the Senators tried to battle
back late but unable to get the job
done against the Tampa Bay Lightning